there's this one map you have to see to
understand the full effects of War right
now there's a civil war happening in
Sudan and like most conflicts it comes
down to two guys who want power and in
the process they're willing to disrupt
the lives of millions of people this map
shows us how many people have had to
flee their country because of this war
these people are leaving their homes and
fleeing to Sudan's neighbors like Chad
and Egypt the reports say that over 5
million people have been displaced
because of this conflict if you want to
understand the roots of this conflict go
check out the whole video we made on the
channel and if you want to better
understand global politics follow along
for more